good morning Hank it's Thursday and the
greatest ever Pizza Miss at least in
terms of shirt sales is about to come to
an end that's right Hank nothing last
forever not even cold November rain and
tomorrow marks the end of week daily
videos and soon you will be unable to
get this shirt or any of the other
amazing pizz Miss stuff available at
pizz miss.com right now but only for the
next couple days now listen Hank I don't
want to end my part of pizzamas on a
bummer note but I do have to take next
week off from Vlog brothers because I'll
be traveling with my family specifically
I'll be traveling to England to see my
friend Mike Berbiglia perform comedy and
my football team AFC Wimbledon perform
tragedy or at least that's what the
betting odds would indicate but you
never know with Wimbledon America's
second favorite fourth tier English
soccer team that most people in this
community keep up with via updates on
dear Hank and John our hit podcast that
unfortunately has been on cancer Hiatus
for the last several months which means
that most of y'all probably don't know
what's happening with AFC Wimbledon
single sentence backstory for anyone
who's new my producer partner rosiana
and I sponsor a fourth tier English
soccer team called AFC Wimbledon who
play in South London and who are owned
by their fans each of whom pay about $25
a year in order to vote on the club's
leadership because of that sponsorship
wimbledon's women's team play with a
partners and health logo on the back of
their shirts and the men's team play
with a dftba logo on the back of their
shorts in that Lial space between left
thigh and buttock the other thing you
need to know about AFC Wimbledon is that
we're bad like there are other teams in
the fourth year of English football who
are owned by Major Hollywood celebrities
or the Saudi government but we are owned
by our fans and so we never have any
money so we've got a beautiful new
stadium owned and built by the fans
that's packed every week what we don't
have is uh money so we're pretty bad
every year we used to be a third tier
English soccer team but then we got
relegated down to the fourth tier
because we were so bad and then we we
barely survived in the fourth tier last
season and this season wasn't looking
like it was going to be any different
except something weird happened which is
that uh we seem like we might be good
like not to brag but if you look at the
table currently AFC Wimbledon are
narrowly ahead of rexam the football
club owned by Ryan Reynolds and Rob
Melaney and we're several spots above
the franchise currently plying its trade
in Milton ke also and this is even more
surprising we're fun to watch this
season we have exciting young players
who score lots of goals and also a
mountain of a man who rolls his shorts
up so much that you can't even see our
logo but more on him in a second so our
star players this year include our
Striker Ali alham who left Iraq as an
infant after his dad was imprisoned by
the Saddam Hussein regime and now has
become an absolute Superstar for both
AFC Wimbledon and the Iraqi national
team I just love him so much also we
have the Mustachio James Tilly who
scored seven goals in his first nine
games for us and out on the other Wing
we've got Aaron sassu an 18-year-old
who's been playing for wimbledon's youth
side since he was 10 in fact there are a
bunch of great players emerging from our
Academy our fullbacks include my
personal hero Jack Curt who's also
played with us since he was 10 and also
Isaac ogera who joined us at the age of
14 we're never going to be the kind of
football club that can buy big stars so
we're going to have to make them and
we've done a really good job of that and
then we have our Central Defenders Ryan
great beard Johnson and Mighty Joe Lewis
Joe Lewis the man with the golden shorts
Joe short shorts Lewis Joe big man small
shorts Lewis Joe we're only here for the
shorts Lewis look at how aggressive L
this man rolls up his shorts you cannot
see our dftba logo and I for one am fine
with it the great thing about AFC
Wimbledon is that if you love an
Underdog Story we keep on delivering
because we're always going to be an
Underdog Story But the argument we've
been making in the 10 years we've been
sponsoring AFC Wimbledon and the 21
years since AFC Wimbledon reformed after
being told by the English FA that there
was no place for a football club in that
community community held assets communal
action
can work it's not easy it doesn't always
work but it can work I know it's just a
football club but what I've learned from
AFC Wimbledon not just on the field but
also their local action group that seeks
to address poverty in the community and
the AFC Wimbledon Foundation what I've
learned from them I've used and we've
used in a lot of our community projects
including trying to get folks to lower
the prices of TB Diagnostics and
treatments and I'll tell you what I'm
sure we're not going to be good all
season I'm sure we're going to lose a
bunch of our best players in the January
transfer window Etc but oh my gosh is it
fun when we're good and holy crap I love
pizza thanks for coming up with this
weird idea Hank I'm going to save her
saying this since I won't get to say it
for a year I will see you tomorrow